il était 8 heures 46 quant à sonner le
glas ce matin à new york
8h46 c'est exactement l'heure à laquelle
le premier avion a percuté la tour nord
du world trade center il ya six ans la
ville a honoré la mémoire de ces
victimes
mais la cérémonie était plus sobre que
d'habitude george bush par exemple était
resté à washington sur place marit
martine laroche-joubert pascal geoffrion
8h46 ce matin le son du glas raisonne
sur ground zero une minute de silence
commence
c'est l'heure à laquelle le premier
avion percute la tour nord du world
trade center il y a 6 ans
pour la première fois les commémorations
se déroule en retrait du site en travaux
les sauveteurs tu les parents des
victimes
liste à tour de rôle les noms des deux
mille sept cent quarante neuf personnes
qui trouvent la mort dans l'effondrement
des deux tours
la douleur est intacte mon frère charles
était très attentif aux autres
c'était aussi un fils aimant une
cérémonie plus discrète que les années
précédentes les à ciel gris et une pluie
fine souligner davantage un code la
tristesse des familles elles seules sont
autorisées à descendre à l'intérieur du
site où leurs proches ont disparu des
fleurs en offrande
un site marquée aussi par la mort la
maladie des sauveteurs sans protection
pour déblayer les décombres
six ans après le 11 septembre
81 % des américains considèrent ces
attentats comme l'événement historique
le plus important de leur vie
aujourd'hui